[Music]
foreign
the newest crop of recipients for their
outstanding Works in creating a better
Singapore and a better world by Design
our hope is that it will really be an
inspiration for generations to come for
visitors to understand how each and
every building can become a vital part
of the community it serves
the mission has always been to change
perceptions with design we believe that
this award helps to push what design is
and who design is for
I'm really proud of this project because
it is not a personal project but a
project that not speaks about repair but
it also represents the designers based
in Singapore
they feel proud and honored to represent
and present Singapore at the World Expo
simultaneously we propose a vision of an
equitable future where architecture and
nature coexist harmoniously
the design and making of Singapore state
courts has been an amazing journey for
us it is the very first high-rise
courthouse in Singapore breaking away
from the more traditional low rise
for us a young design firm it's very
important that to be recognized to be
able to show our design and celebrate
this design excellence
in the future as we confront with some
of the most intractable challenges
facing our globe I believe landscape
will play a more important role in
helping to ameliorate some of these
challenges
Architects are dreamers only dreamers
will create something you've never seen
before
and perhaps only dreamer will bring to
us a better City for Better Living
[Music]